[Music]
growing questions now over the sexual
assault allegation against Joe Biden by
a former staffer as new details emerge
some commentators now wondering if the
media has a double standard are they
covering these accusations the same way
they covered Republican allegations like
those against Brett Kavanaugh Dave Rubin
is the host of the Rubin report and
author of don't burn this book and is
just out today I've had a look at it
it's really really good Dave one of the
things you talk about in here is how
your eyes were open to media bias over
the years and I wonder how you see this
situation yeah well Dana you've written
a couple of books excuse me and you know
that it you sit on them for a while so I
finished this thing back in July but one
of the things that I write about chapter
8 is all about how to spot fake news and
we seem to be in an endless time of fake
news these days but people think when
you talk about fake news that it just
means that the story is completely
fabricated or that the headline doesn't
match the story itself but actually
another I would say more pernicious
subtle type of fake news is when the
media ignores a story that doesn't fit
their narrative so when the Brett
Kavanaugh hearings were happening every
allegation was printed on the front page
of the New York Times and CNN ran with
it in Washington Post and the rest of it
for weeks and weeks and weeks I was
actually on tour with Jordan Peterson in
Europe at the time and people literally
were coming up to me on the streets of
Dublin and asking me what I thought
about the Brett Kavanaugh allegations
well now Joe Biden has allegations and
I'm not here to say whether the
allegations in one case or the other
case were true but two different people
have allegations who have two different
political allegiances and for weeks now
on Twitter and on YouTube people have
seen these Tara Reid allegations there's
this video from over 25 years ago that
has now been confirmed by Tara Reid
herself that it was her mother calling
in to Larry King's show to say that her
daughter had been sexually accosted by a
senator now again that doesn't make the
allegations true in and of themselves
but the point is one of type of fake
news that
exist is when the media ignores
something and because Joe Biden is a
Democrat because he's a lefty he gets a
pass from mainstream media where we know
if this was a conservative and we have
evidence of it in the case of Brett
Kavanaugh wouldn't get a pass and people
really need to wake up today see you let
me beat you a tweet from Alyssa Milano
she said I'm aware of the new
developments and Tara Reid's accusation
against Joe Biden I want Tara like every
other survivor to have the space to be
heard and seen without being used as
fodder I hear and see you tarus a
hashtag me too but really because Dave
in about 45 minutes or so I guess Joe
Biden is having a virtual Town Hall
about women's issues and we found out
that Hillary Clinton is going to be his
special guest and will be endorsing him
today yeah well we know this is just
nonsense I mean when when me two started
we had to believe all women and every
allegation was taken as simple fat then
when it goes against their guy I mean
Alyssa Milano she's been one of the
biggest pushers of the me2 thing now I
believe it was well intentioned but then
it sort of lost control and it's just
there to sort of take out everybody but
then when it's one of her guys well now
we have to think about it a little bit
more and I think this type of hypocrisy
is in many ways why we see mainstream
media collapsing because if you don't
call it as it is but you only call it as
you wish to be well then people are
gonna see that and this is sort of the
asymmetry that we now have with the
online media and what happens on YouTube
and Twitter and elsewhere and by the way
Fox is very good at this because you
guys actually cover the outlier stories
that the other networks ignore me Chuck
this is the type of thing that the New
York Times why has CNN not reported on
this story as far as I know as of us
right talking about this right now on
some on a video that happened on their
own network yeah I mean people start to
see it if you're looking for more honest
and thoughtful conversations about
politics instead of non-stop yelling
check out our politics playlist and if
you want to watch full interviews on a
variety of topics watch our full episode
playlists all right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell